until now if you changed mobile phones
regularly this often meant owning
multiple incompatible phone chargers
these different charges are a pain for
users and produce waste which harms the
environment
today a single common mobile phone
charger which can be used to charge
different mobile phones made by
different manufacturers has been made
possible
based on the micro usb standard the new
charger is compatible with data enabled
mobile phones and soon these kinds of
mobile phones will be predominant on the
eu market
the new charger exists thanks to the eu
powers of persuasion
it managed to convince manufacturers who
make up 90 of the european mobile phone
market to agree on a common charger
model
a common charger will make everyone's
lives easier
no more worrying about forgetting your
charger you'll be able to charge your
mobile phone anywhere you need to using
any available charger
as there will be fewer chargers produced
and sold this means less electronic
waste being produced
in the long term introducing the common
universal charger is expected to reduce
electronic waste by more than 50 000
tons per year
today there are more than a billion
charges hanging around in draws
the common charger
good news for consumers good news for
the environment
you